girl power a local girls camp working to
improve lives this summer their focus
something so many girls need help with
self-esteem mary jane billy is joining
us live at the walnut recreation center
mary jane you got a chance to check out
this new camp so tell us what's it all
about
well you know john and heather it's just
so heartwarming to see how much this
camp has really helped these girls make
new friends and even shape their
confidence it's hosted by local
non-profit rescue the children and
they're all about changing the world one
child at a time now the camp is free and
it lasts up to four weeks it's focused
on educating and empowering young girls
ages 9 to 16 years old rescue the
children non-profit owner lasandra
morrison hopes to boost their
self-esteem and self-worth while
educating them on realistic scenarios
like etiquette health hygiene peer
pressure and much more as a 14 year old
girl i needed this and so they did not
have a lot of these programs around when
i was growing up and so i felt as though
with the generation and the times
changing and the things that they're
exposed to this is needed i was
pressured so
much to do things i didn't want to do
and learning that
how to like
set boundaries for myself it definitely
changed some things and now i'm able to
stop doing things that i don't want to
do
now this is morrison's first year
hosting the girls camp and says
donations and volunteers are always
welcome as this will help make the camp
possible for next year the community is
also invited to the girls camp ceremony
completion
event that's taking place this saturday
from 12 to 2. it's going to be here at
the walnut recreation center so if
you're interested on making a donation
or coming out to just check it out to
have
if you want to enroll your childhood
next year you're more than welcome to
come that's here at the walnut
recreation center on cheyenne and walnut
reporting live mary jane ballisa live
local now